hi there Steve Kaufman here
the linguist on language I want to talk
today about non-native teachers it's a
little bit dark here
non-native teachers of languages and
with particular reference to the
controversy which we have right now in
the state of Arizona in the United
States about the apparent decision of
the Board of Education there to ask
those teachers who teach English and who
have a strong accent or major problems
with grammar to no longer teach English
that those teachers should teach other
subjects or try to improve but they
shouldn't be teaching English if they
have a strong accent or don't or make a
lot of mistakes in grammar this has
caused a tremendous amount of
consternation amongst teachers and other
people who feel this is unjust and so
forth so I'd like to comment on this
from a number of different points of
view first of all I'd like to talk about
the role of non-native teachers and then
I will talk about this my view of the
situation in Arizona it so far as
non-native teachers are concerned the
vast majority of language teachers in
the world are non native speaking
teachers and I am quite sure that a
non-native speaking teacher teacher can
be just as good a teacher as a native
speaking teacher and nowadays there is
so much content available via the
internet and other places audio
obviously text was always there but
there is just so many ways in which a
teacher can bring the language spoken by
the native speaker to his or her
students that native the non-native
speaking teacher can be just as
effective and in some ways if the
non-native speaking teacher understands
the predicament
of the learner better that non-native
speaking teacher might be better able to
inspire and courage the learner so
speaking objectively I have nothing
against non native speaking teachers and
they are necessarily going to be the
main workforce around the world because
in most places where they teach foreign
languages that foreign language by
definition isn't spoken in the local
community so that's first of all now you
may know from my previous videos that I
believe that dependence on a teacher is
not a good thing that learners should
learn to become independent learners now
a native speaking teacher or a
non-native speaking teacher it can be
equally good in principle at encouraging
the learner to become independent and
that to me is the ultimate role of the
teacher to make the learner an
independent learner and I see no reason
why a non-native speaking teacher
couldn't do that just as well as a
native speaking teacher so that's point
number one
however because most teachers see their
role as that of teaching in the
classroom teaching the language rather
than cultivating and creating and
nurturing independent learners to the
extent that the teacher is teaching a
language there's no question that the
native speaker will make a better
teacher and the reason in my view is
this and that is that that a language is
different from other subjects like math
or physics or so forth it's different
because as I've said before in my videos
the attitude of the learner is so
important and a native speaker in my
view is a greater inspiration for most
people if I want to learn Chinese I'm
much more inspired by the idea that I'm
face to face with a Chinese person or if
I'm learning
hindu or polish or mongolian i don't
want to be face to face with an American
or a British person or you know Swedish
person I want to be face to face with
the native speaker that to me inspires
me that's stimulating I want to be like
that person I want to join that person's
language group so that's much more
motivating I cannot imagine that foreign
students who travel to Spain or England
or France or Germany or Japan to learn
the local language would accept to have
a non-native speaking teacher if they go
to Shanghai to learn Chinese they don't
want to be taught by an American or an
Indian or a Japanese so I think that
that there's generally speaking people
are more inclined to want to learn from
a native speaker now as I've said before
at what point do you need that
interaction with a native speaker in my
mind not very early there's lots you can
do on your own before you need that
interaction but when the interaction
comes along I think it's more of an
inspiration to be dealing with a native
speaker but a skilled native speaker
non-native speaker could perhaps
encourage the same kind of enthusiasm in
a learner I don't know but I personally
and I think a majority of people have
given the choice would rather have a
native speaker so that's the first point
that I would like to make with regard to
the situation in Arizona what happened
there was that Arizona has more and more
Hispanic people moving in some years ago
the government of the state decided to
bring in a lot of spanish-speaking
teachers they recruited them in Latin
America and they were going to make the
state of Arizona bilingual now they have
a different government as I understand
it and this government doesn't think
it's a good idea for the state to be
bilingual so they're trying to cut back
and the demographics in Arizona are such
that in grade 12 something like 12% of
the students are spanish-speaking but in
grade 1 45% of the students are
spanish-speaking so in other words there
is a bit of a language struggle taking
place in the state of Arizona which is
not unlike what I have you know
experienced in Quebec or what I read
about in Catalonia what I read about in
Latvia or Estonia where you have two
language groups struggling for power is
the state of Arizona going to become a
bilingual state or is English going to
prevail as the language of the state the
group that is in power right now that
were voted in demography in the
democratically want Arizona to be
english-speaking so that means that
anybody with the name Sanchez Lopez or
or you know whatever who arrives from
Mexico they would like him in the second
generation to be an English speaker just
as in Quebec which when I grew up
Montreal was 30% english-speaking the
government they decided that Quebec was
going to be unilingual French in order
to ensure the survival of the French
language they didn't want to become more
and more Anglophile and similarly in
Latvia where there are only a million
and some Latvian speakers in the world
they decided that they wanted to push
back and insist that any Russian
speakers who lived in Latvia should have
to learn the language so the idea of
these language struggles are quite
common but of course the reaction
amongst many of the sort of left-leaning
teacher fraternity to the situation in
Arizona is to call it all racist and
bigoted and stuff well to me it's just a
matter of democratic choice if the
citizens of Arizona vote in a government
that wants the state to be bilingual
they'll be bilingual if they vote in a
government that says we want the state
to be unilingual that's what they end up
with but in all of this what really
surprised me was
because I happened to be on this
listserv where English teachers comment
on different things was this to find out
that 25 percent of English as a second
language teachers in the United States
are non-native speakers 25 percent of
the teachers who teach immigrants
English are non-native speakers I find
that surprising not because those
teachers can't be effective within the
limits of what you can do in the
classroom and I think that there are
severe limits to what you can do in a
classroom but because I think that a
majority of people would naturally
prefer to have native speakers as
teachers whether justified or not that
would be the preference of a majority of
learners I think I could be wrong
certainly that would be my preference so
I was surprised to find out that 25% of
all English as a second language
teachers are non-native speakers anyway
there you have it I don't think the
situation in Arizona is racist
I think non-native speakers can be
effective but I prefer native speakers
thank you bye